You know it does and i'm graham dunstan.
I was the director of the aquarius festival in nine hundred seventy three and a came back to name and.
As a name and resident. Between nine hundred seventy four like seventy four nine hundred eighty.
And worked on community development in him but so i have an intimate association with the post aquarius.
Community development. Their name and if you count again. It will. Goes back to the beginning of the sixty's.
And i went from school in dun troon. As a military could it. And i became very disillusioned with what was happening.
As a cadet. In the army. Just worked out that the army wasn't for me.
This was that the time of intense bastardize ation. Initiation the same time the university. Only did the.
Duntroon was trying to become a cademy in degrees. So i would want to get it.
To have economic training in the same time your life was run by drill sergeants and.
Most immediate concerns was polishing your boots. So i sort of distinguish myself academically but had increasingly.
Problems became the most. Punished get it done true.
And during that time i was under a lot of pressure to resign and get out.
And i was hanging in there so i could get the academic qualification would give me some exemptions at university.
And the university.
Appealed to me then to be some sort of salvation it was my ideal it was the place i really wanted to be.
And so it was that i enrolled at university firstname and university for a year doing engineering.
And i was approached by an easier. Asked to attend meetings right.
To see what had happened was i thought well i've got all this military training when i'm going to do with it. And.
So i applied to join the squadron university squadron in the hope that i'd learn to fly. And i was rejected.
But they said we got something more important for you. Approached by these two guys from a zero saying.
We want you to attend meetings and give us reports about what's going on. And being. Straight out of the army and.
Straight out of school having no political sophistication of two or less that will. Sounds like a to me. I want to.
I want to go to these meetings anyway so it became my regular lunch time.
At the university not to sit with engineering students down the engineering faculty
but actually plug into all these meetings that were happening. And of course the momentum as i tended to.
The more interested i became in the danger of the lift
and particularly the information about what was happening in southeast asia.
Because i had some inkling in this when i was at duntroon they were already. Briefing us about southeast asia.
And preparing the. Offices for a southeast asian war.
And part of the tension with duntroon was they changed the conditions that they announced that they weren't going to
accept any more resignations of officers that were actually going to build up the army. At that time.
So if i'd expected to commission i don't train i would have been in for a life time is what they are telling us and.
So i thought well this is the other side of the coin finding out from the left. What's going on in southeast asia.
The year after. I did when you were at melbourne university then transferred to the university of new south wales and.
Again attended meetings got very interested in the labor club and.
The difference between the university of new south wales.
And the university of melbourne was the university new south wales a very new campus in the didn't have the
infrastructure of student clubs and societies. The old university had. So i felt.
We hope to start creating it so i started organizing my own meetings my own talks. And again i was approached by a.c.s.
and To get back into it i think i had about four meetings at this time
but eventually i was elected president of the labor club. And i had to tell is it time to compromising.
To be president of the labor club at university new south wales. So i've. I became.
Thanks to the initiation that i was you know offered me a very active. Student organizer. And involved in the.
And this will moratorium. Initial learn and teach ins. And inviting people to talk about.
What was happening on the campus. And from the labor club i became.
Present the students union an interest of the student newspaper.
Not full time student activist along with a pool time engineering degree. And.
Became one of the principal organizers of the protest movement. On the campus.
I came back to the you know graduated in one in sixty seven and. Work. The next year sixty eight.
Fruit which i can remember.
I've had a job as a computer programmer for a while and then came back to the university nine hundred seventy.
To do a degree in sociology and was again invited to reengage in student politics. And that was the year of.
The when he begun editing. The record i was the director of student publications.
So i was right back in the thick of the organizing. And by this time i'd got to appreciate this.
These were the moratorium years got to appreciate that.
What was really working with the antiwar movement any conscription movement. Was that.
Not so much giving people information and. Talking at people. Public meetings. But so. But more the.
The cultural movement the sense of every time we had a protest in the street. It was a festival.
This time was sort of introduced to the. Thing. And i one day. The sort of a statement about the power of joy.
And i begin to realize that the way you can create cultural movement remember i was doing social najee was to create.
Events where people should do it.
So i got very interested in this strategy
and whenever we organize an event on the campus we'd always do it with the band. It was like a celebration.
So i got very interested in festivals. Nine hundred seventy one.
The aquarius foundation of the australian union of students had a festival i think was the first aquarius festival.
On the campus of the university. Of i you know it was a in the national strike the national university.
And this was an extraordinary festival. And i went along. And was delighted that.
At the the activity because students come from all around the straight at this time the street in union of students was
a very strong union.
It had an escalating membership there's more cia's were brought online and sort of welcomed into the fold
and every student was paying fifty cents to be a member.
So it had a sort of an increasing budget and had more and more departments. It was opening up with it.
And they starting new students at that time was responsible. If they had travel.
Brands that it sort of taken off like a rocket. It's. Abscam all.
Department which was regionally about raising money to get students or. Aboriginal students through university it.
Had picked up on the land. Land rights issue the education department.
Writing the agenda for the labor party the education agenda for the labor party.
International pop and all these kind of things happening.
It had been an organization had previously been under control of the cia funding and stuff
and it sort of done this huge turn during the late sixty's in the early seventy's.
And one of the things that it created was a cultural arm and. The idea was that the queerest foundation would.
The responsible for campus too is of artists and speakers.
And it was a vision of this sort of national organizing body. And then every two years it would organize a fist of all.
Which was originally conceived of as being.
Bringing all the aid into vasty groups together so that all the dramatic societies would come and perform.
At this festival and all the debating society. Would come. If you're ready.
All the dramatic societies and all the debating the size the cars the size would come together in one place
and have a festival. Well when they came together it. I knew in nine hundred seventy one. Something else.
Spun off the synergy of the situation was having all those embassies and symbols of authority.
The students were extremely reactive and like every day. A protest would be organized.
So that the for mentor of the of the.
The festival wasn't so much around the program of events which was quite interesting in itself.
But the student activity that arose spontaneously from all the student activists coming from all around the stranger.
To one place. Now i was greatly stimulated by this and. After i returned to sydney. I had a meeting with. Johnny allen.
And journey along with an old friend who'd been doing.
Arts drama degree at the university and i had known him through east. Theatre organization. And he.
After leaving university had taken up an organized. Among other things the thought of the arts factory.
Sorry he was which was like the first rock and roll being you.
And was very interested in organizing festivals kind of cultural festivals in one hundred seventy one i got to say i
was the editor of the university paper against the rancor.
And i was running it in on the theme of on the counterculture had been greatly influenced by theodore roosevelt's book
called the making of the counterculture. So i was looking around to see what sort of. As we're coming.
As a result of the impact of the antiwar move any conscription movement what sort of cultural. Things were rising.
And each edition of the paper each week. We would produce.
Invite a guest editor in and explore a particular theme so the themes. Typically were.
Anti psychiatry ecology health foods. Spirituality drugs.
Such themes such things and i've had to with the talk to johnny on about some of this.
And we had a meeting we was at the why of all places.
And johnny had been at the curtis festival in at i and u two and we sort of set them compared notes
and both agreed that it was an extraordinary event. To bring students together. This time.
And probably the program was getting in the way of the festival.
And wouldn't be a great idea if we would organize the fist of all students. And not have the standard arts. Program.
But rather take the fifth of all the way from university whether it had all the symbols of authority to react to
and ask the question what are we for run. Make it a life style festival and put the question to people.
What do you believe in what kind of future you. Do you want to create. Well. We walked up and down the street to the y.
Beach talking about this. One of will think we finished with agreement.
That i would write an article about it for a straight line. And that you know it's right in university student.
A straight in you know a student's publication called national you. Which i did.
And it was published and i forgot all about them. Done that.
And the nine hundred seventy two i was teaching and electron boys high school
when i received a call from the organizers the aquarius.
Foundation saying we're advertising for the festival director not in seventy three.
We really like what you wrote in the paper. Why don't you apply. So i think teaching was going to really suck.
And i put it in that location and. Was flown to melbourne and interviewed. And at the time.
The strenuous students had invited i've been in look out for a sort of the who i haven't really because the sort of.
Third wolf the last of the. About going to say. Development in the third world. Alternative options and.
Particularly deschooling.
And that's kind of and i was sort of blown out by the ideas that this man was coming up with and.
I was it was after one of these talks that i heard from the interviewing committee that i'd got the job and.
They'd also.
They said we'd also interviewed for another position the director of the queerest foundation and do you know.
John i thought i called johnny allen he's also from sydney. So it was like.
Fight through us together and he was johnny allen
and graeme dunstan appointed to the only two positions in the aquarius foundation.
The only two paid positions to organize.
Among other things the queerest of the one hundred seventy three so we had a blueprint. Already worked out.
And then we had the job of putting it together.
There were two things that were required for that one was to get the message across to people that they should come as
tribes and. Bring something to present to the festival. It is not.
We had this thing that this is not to consume with this to that we have to make this festival.
So if you got a particular thing or. You're presenting. Like the alternative community telephone.
That the time was hot in sydney. And it was like an information same service. Run by stephen warman and.
Horan will walk out of the get the horn horn buy a dell horn. And.
We asked them to help us publicize this will but also bring up their ideas about community and.
Come to the fist of will and bring their ideas about.
Communications and so they did eventually very helpful in distributing information about the festival.
And they came as a big try this tool and also another example would be. The feeble foundry. Gribble street duran.
So that the whole home will bakery.
That developed the it was also kind of a community center and tribe and they agreed to come
and not have you come there you can put the bread making techniques in top of the wood bakery and they bake the bread.
For the festival. And that was the kind of reach we the message we wanted to put out to people.
And the other issue was like finding a site for the festival. That wasn't a university campus.
And wasn't in the same time and place where people could camp and. Reflect in would rather than now.
And that was my job to find the site.
And we reasoned that the southern states were too cold and queensland was too hostile politically and. Sort of than.
The northern rivers area the north coast of new south wales seemed like the best bits.
And it also had a mythology going forward that we'd heard about this mythical place.
And surfing paradise called byron bay. And there was something happening behind. Mom and bindi. That were rumors off.
So we set up the set off to explore this area and.
I have a ties in the local papers for a suitable so i'm a kind of looking fool. You know.
Three hundred acres of something. You know. Of idyllic countryside that would. Might become a community afterwards and.
The system would least something substantial after it. After we had it. And i had absolutely no response.
Right no one answered the ads and i travelled around used to get around real estate agents
and i was getting exhausted and.
Consuming lots of petrol running up lots of petrol driving around the north coast looking at properties.
And we were running out of time it was getting into. November.
And that decision had to be in place for the annual general meeting of the the union in january. And i was.
We had the support of cole james from the acting school at the university of sydney and.
A spectacle of the telephone long distance saying i'm having the luck call.
And he says yes and we're running out of time because cold. Sort of it offered to sort of do the stock design police.
Students on designing the side to the festival.
And he said well maybe we're looking in the wrong direction maybe we should be looking at the town because if it's.
This like that that the cost of putting in the infrastructure of roads and telephones
and pad all that kind of stuff is going to be enormous and we don't really have it together.
So when we think about looking for a village we could do something that has a show ground that we can buy stuff on.
And he would know. I've been driving through this place called niman which is really pretty.
And it's got lots of empty shops. And hospital and. Looks pretty good.
So i went and made inquiries and made contact with the show society an image.
Is that the first port of call and they said we're interested and. We had a meeting. Famous meeting.
Called james came up from sydney. And. We we raised the time to meeting women. And the executive of the.
The management committee the name of an agriculture and industrial show society. Society.
The agricultural and industrial society of member and. Were collected around the woman more in the main street.
And we approached from the south end of the main street. And walked up the middle of the road.
Met them in the middle of the. High noon and. I mean that we were able to do those things that.
Five pm in the afternoon. In the in the because there's very little traffic in the streets. And.
And we went i think we would step in the pack. We're back to them. The park behind the war memorial.
And they had their position was that they were interested in the idea of hosting a festival. And.
But they thought it was a major decision. In the town.
It should be go from the station so it was agreed that we'd have a public meeting and.
So we set the date and we booked the whole. Went away and then we came back again for the public meeting.
Did all the publicity we called our way and. I think it was near the middle like.
November and nine hundred seventy two. We had them.
A public meeting we came from all around the place we made it a focal point. Full. Planning the festival.
And people came down from brisbane people came across from ahmed al. And sydney and. We came mooney.
I mean people from the. The dig a newspaper in melbourne came up to to watch it to see this public me.
And i derive a couple of days early.
And spent the day of the festival going around and distributing the pamphlets about meeting
and talking to many people i could personally. So that when we got to the meeting room about.
Probably recall about two hundred people. In the town hall and women. And it was an extraordinary meeting.
Basically as we attracted a lot of extraordinary people to come to the meeting for example.
The guy called boma parea who.
At that time was organizing a group called hopper which was a kind of a theatre group come. Concert organizing group.
And whole food supply.
Associated with the university of queensland they had to shut off the campus
but they used to organize their events on the campus.
And i would approach them to see if they'd be interested sitting at the food cooperated this part of the fistful. And.
Bowman is an extraordinary guy an extraordinary performer he went on to these a performer his own robin went on to sort
of produce the. Applying for thoughts that is that all. We don't get and his great.
Lone frizzy hair and sort of the glasses in there or a wry grin.
And he was there a printing room with a plastic millet. Right.
So he's in full performance and if anyone showed any disaffection
or grumpiness the volm would creep up behind him give him a bump on the head. So that you know.
Laughter was produced by also showed one of the sixteen millimeter movies that they made which consisted of students
who these guys are running around with put a paper. Behind. You know. Streams of toilet paper.
I hadn't seen the movie for a show
and was trying to sort of an example of the kind of films we teach i'm totally incomprehensible myself
and have it in him and people. But there was it just a feeling of goodwill. That this was an exciting bunch of people.
And the music because we had live music we perform for them.
It was going to say that this was going to be something special something different.
So we had a tremendous amount of goodwill. Generated.
And also we had the support of the local policeman bob and bob mush was a policeman with a good heart
and he was concerned about the economic downturn. Of nieman. The at the that the time of the festival the school.
The central school was threatened with downgrading was going to become a primary school so even the people in the.
You know just. The thirty's of high school would have to travel is more.
They were talking about closing the hospital which.
You know than even community and work so hard to create and build in the first place.
And so that the pensioners and the all people living the town would have to travel to lease more for the services.
And bob is a bit of an entrepreneur they had on the saudi had a sort of restock a pet food business they used to
recycle the caucus is in the area and did cows and did. The listens.
And he wanted to see move into price develop in him and so he was. When we say well look.
You queers festival put this town on the map
and you'll certainly get a lot of young people moving back he was like totally supportive of the idea.
Any think that helped regenerate him and it was going to support.
So he didn't attend the meeting but he wrote a letter.
You know to the fist of all it to the meeting which was read aloud and it was. Had a great impact.
The impact of the head on.
What must his career as a policeman was also that spirit was kind of drummed out of the police force of being so
outspoken. And as the book. And the big question was asked of course inevitably what about drugs and them.
We all remember saying at the time that the queerest festival was not a sunday school picnic.
We're talking about university students here and.
And that marijuana allusions were part of the culture there's no way we could prevent that.
Being present at the festival and. The vote was taken with.
You know it was like almost unanimous there are only a handful of people i would say no more than six people who voted
against having the festival. So we were. Triumphant. Take that down south to the. To the meeting.
The annual meeting of the straining union students and out a job was then to get the money for the budget.
You know to get a budget. As a major event. For the student finances.
Well that was the most amazing event in it so you can imagine that there are lots of. Demands lots.
Being put on the budget of the straining union of students and. We worked at it we would allow.
Entertainers in singers and dancers and the like house stuff and we did them a spectacular presentation.
I remember i wore a dress. And the spotless.
I've met people since the late eighty's were in melbourne i met a guy in an advertising agency that all your gram
dunston. Are. Remember i was that sort of. You know with the hind the a is.
Student politician we're going to my thirst destroying union students conference and you did this amazing presentation.
It's the best presentation of ever saying up.
Always want when i do presentations my clients are always trying to emulate.
The flair
and possess of the prison that in any way what what happened was that we we knocked their socks off basically and.
We had total support for the festival and we had got through with an open ended bunch of.
Of a we had something like twenty thousand dollars in notting seventy three money.
To produce this money but by see it was open ended we could do whatever we needed to do to get this festival happening.
Which we went away and did. So. Having got the money and the responsibilities were again split. Johnny on did them.
The spruiking he was. Took the job on of going round two straight talking up the fist of all.
And i had the job of sort of getting the side organized in women and sort of preparing the town for..
The strategy we adopted for the publisher he was to work through the. The student papers and. We got h.
With the student papers at the major campuses to give us and.
In addition of the paper which was the principal used in seventy one and. Have a guest editor i mean and.
We filled the. The paper with stories about people who coming to the festival.
People giving their rides about the future so we had.
Called james talking about alternative architecture and low low energy. Houses noise kind of stuff.
And organic gardening and. You know. So it was always a fascinating a riot of ideas being presented.
And because we never really we had posters funded by the peta status and foundation. Is a bit of an irony at the time.
And they never funded the eucharist foundation again after they found out. The festival is about.
But basically we didn't use any of the established media we didn't advertise in any of them in the media the.
Television radio. The press. And it was only. It was a very successful campaign we said.
You know a publishing deal that the word of the festival would be carried on the lips of the counterculture the people
who were really interested in these ideas would tell their friends and then get together to come. And i remember.
People scoffing about this and.
There is a danger because people carry negative messages much more readily
and then there's the positive ones they've got to keep the divide really really high.
But it was only about three weeks before the festival when the first articles. Peed in the sitting room here old.
Acknowledging that something strange was happening in him and something extraordinary is happening.
Like that you know the word is out the name of the place to go to.
So it's a very successful campaign to court the established. Precise unawares.
And johnny allen was going around australia.
Talking these things up he was assisted by a theatre group that he put together called the white company.
Which did the same thing in song and dance and sing anthems and create the mood. Some of them. We used to. I mean.
When the systems we were always faced with the ritual would burn some incense and sort of. Essential oils on.
Chalk all kinds. If you dealing with those who have a big temple. You know. It's sort of.
It was easier with a breathable amount of incense who i mean we did it in the open.
In joan pinned it was the thought of the jumping the from the last laugh. Tell them oh.
It's going to be on the control we actually had to leave the house. Billowy incidence got a good thing about it.
And the other think got out of control was the white company or totally inspirational but there were all.
All had their individual performance trips. There are lots of vegas begin. Sort of bouncing. Of each other and.
Towards the end of the two are they got more and more interested in primal scream therapy.
The object of the exercise was to convey to people feeling for the festival and. It was the end of the.
What kept his promotion.
The feeling of fist it was this one's primal scream this is for who exactly is going around school really.
Had my doubts about whether the successful promotion at the end but.
We got the agony and the what kept me were fantastic. So. Meanwhile back in women.
The wood got out and we started up a food kitchen. Which we called the rainbow cafe and. We offered very one.
We couldn't afford to pay for people. Anyone who wanted to work on the preparation the festival. Come along.
And we would three them mixed into the labor. And in the beginning this worked wonderfully and. Yes we we printed some.
Some money and called women braids and. An exchange has a name and braid.
If you work the vest and you paid him in bread you get your food at nine.
And the rainbow cafe itself every evening was like. A wonderland of entertainment. And i would sit around with.
You know who was set on the floor and low tables. One of the early. Kind of cultural impact on women was at least.
We savage tables with the counter table. Going to cut its legs off. It was a fashion that.
We sit on the floor and we did together and then we'd have a talk about the progress of the festival
and then we'd seen in every night.
You know they'd be a new group of people arriving in town these triple doors
and we would be blown up by the lightest performance or that the lightest.
Right if the people would come and say they want to do.
It was a magical place and the reputation of the rainbow cafes sort of.
The cafe of the universe was sort of built in that his days.
And what happened for me as an organizer with it and this was wonderful payoff of the.
Local newman community and we used. Used to invite. Local business people and residents. To come dine with us.
Of course they would be blown out because we usually finish with a dance everyone dancing together
and hollering handle this kind of stuff and. Wonderful uplifting.
Spiritual experiences these when they would go back until the friends and neighbors
and we had extraordinary good will in the beginning. It was like magic in the streets.
There was a woman who arrived in the village called margaret sullivan. Margaret was an irish.
Singer touring a straighter at the time.
And she was going north and she decided to do two of our name and because you'd heard about this place
and hopped out of the cab. And stayed for seventies.
And she became a welcomer so that any new face that arrived in town was you know margaret would go and introduce him
and find a place for miss kind of stuff and she was also a liaison officer.
So you go and talk to the residents and find out their concerns and.